Hey!
How's it going?
Hey! What's up?
I've had the worst day...
I'm just so SICK of everything going wrong
all the time!
And now it looks like I'm going to lose my job.
[Music]
Well...just talk to Janet. Talk to Janet...
see if you can move into her department.
[Music]
Just talk to Janet?! What's Janet got to do with it?!
Why would I wanna work in her department? I don't even like Janet!
[Solitary note of music]
This is good! This is really good
because we've been talking about this for ages. You don't, you don't want to be there!
And the only reason you would be is because of the guilt...
and now they've taken the guilt away...you're free!
This is... If you think about it, this is the best thing that could have happened.
How on earth is staring down the barrel of unemployment
SUDDENLY the best thing that could have happened?!
[music]
It's not good! It's not a good situation
but that's how life is and that sucks.
Great! Just...just accept this. This...this is what's happening.
That is NOT what I need you to say!
[music]
What we can do is make you feel better
run you a nice bath,
order in some pizza,
sit and watch a film or something...
Right! Is that literally your solution to every single problem in the world?!
Have a bath and a pizza?
I DON'T WANNA HAVE A BATH AND A PIZZA!
Just shove the pizza in your mouth and STOP speaking for a second!
[Sighs]
[Music]
I'm gonna stop trying to solve everything and...just
listen to you.
So...
I got up really early for the meeting, and they cancelled both trains...
Oh! My train was delayed as well, it was a bit of a...
Yeah! ...I had to get on a bus, it was raining. I didn't have my umbrella,
so I turned up 45 minutes late looking like a drowned rat
to find Malcolm
doing my presentation to the entire team. Didn't give me any credit for it...
Come here...
[sighs heavily]
Thank you
[Music continues]
You can support this channel by hitting the like and subscribe button. Cheers!